THAT COLLISION CAN'T BE LET GO
AS NOTHING.
>> M. Jackson: CHRIS PAUL IS
CLAPPING.
WE UNDERSTAND THERE'S ADVERSITY.
LET'S SETTLE DOWN AND TAKE BACK
CONTROL OF THIS GAME.
>> M. Jones: JAMES MISSING AGAIN
AT THE FOUL LINE.
WHISTLE.
JAMES GOES DOWN HARD TO THE
COURT.
CARUSO AND PAYNE GET INTO IT.
MONTREZL HARRELL RUNS INTO CAM
PAYNE AND COACHES LEAVE THE
BENCH AREA AS THINGS BECOME A
LITTLE BIT CONTENTIOUS HERE.
>> Jeff: IT STARTED WITH CHRIS
PAUL BLOCKING OUT LeBRON JAMES
WHEN HE WAS UP IN THE AIR ON THE
MISSED FREE THROW.
THEN IT WAS CARUSO AND CAM PAYNE
INVOLVED IN A SEPARATE ISSUE.
>> M. Jones: LeBRON IS SHAKEN
UP.
HE'S DOWN ON ONE KNEE ON THE
COURT.
>> Jeff: HE LANDED HARD.
>> M. Jackson: HE'S HOLDING THAT
LEFT SHOULDER.
>> M. Jones: THAT'S ANOTHER LOOK
AT IT.
THERE'S HARRELL THAT CAME IN
LATE ON PAYNE.
THERE'S CHRIS PAUL BLOCKING HIM
OUT.
>> Jeff: THAT GOT CALLED A FOUL.
>> Referee: LOOSE BALL FOUL ON
CHRIS PAUL THAT LEADS TO THE